remember democracy dies in darkness
trump the most transparent pro
pro press president in history probably
he would
talk at length for hours to report as
he'd make fun of them but he would talk
he was open to them
joe biden doesn't do that sort of thing
and lori lightfoot now in
chicago mayor of chicago is saying she's
only going to grant one-on-one
interviews
to black and brown journalists
she is this according to a spokesman who
says that now she's in her two-year
midway point as mayor and she's only
going to give one-on-one interviews to
black or brown journalists it is
tired and cliche and pointless to to
observe that if the situation were
reversed of course
this would be an international incident
and there would be a huge outcry but i i
don't even want to
focus on that point because it just
doesn't matter there's just different
sets of standards right there's one set
of standards
for the black lives matter terrorists
who burn the country to the ground
and there's one set of standards for the
horn guy and the guy who took pelosi's
podium and the standards for the horn
guy are much much harsher than for the
blm terrorists and that's just the way
it is and so
lori lightfoot a black mayor can come
out and say i'm only going to give
interviews to black and brown
journalists and
the reason here of course is
statistically she's looking and saying
black people vote democrat much more so
than
white people do so that's going to give
me a political advantage but also if
you're already saying i'm going to
discriminate on the journalists i talk
to
then they can get much more specific far
beyond just the skin color they can say
okay there's a leftist journalist
there's another leftist
there are plenty of black people who are
conservative i don't think she'd give an
interview to candace owens for instance
but or larry elder or somebody but she
this is just
an excuse to discriminate and she's
going to get away with that
because the sense of reality that we
have
is contrary to reality itself
the ideology being pushed on us is that
this country is in a white supremacist
patriarchal christian theocracy and of
course it's totally the opposite of that
it's totally the only racial
discrimination the only racism that's
permitted and actually promoted by
society
is against white people and to a lesser
degree against asian people but also
against asian people especially
university emissions
and things like that the only
religion that it's perfectly fine to
castigate and mock
is christianity that our perception of
things is very different from reality
if we tim ryan is very barely but
makes a good point if we are going to
have a country we need to be living in
reality and that means conservatives
need to get a little bit tougher about
articulating and enforcing that reality
a point i make a great length in my
opinion
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now for pre-order i'm
michael knowles i'll see you tomorrow
hey there are you living in the demi
lovato fantasy land you probably are if
you have not run that bell if you have
not subscribed
because you all you're doing is swimming
in this morass of delusion and fantasy
but what you got to do is live in this
reality-based community okay ring that
bell
like subscribe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you